[Música]
boa noite gente me perdoem seu parecer
nervosa porque eu tô mesmo e falar da
gente às vezes é um pouco difícil não é
mas eu vou tentar o máximo a prova
aproximar vocês de mim e queria convidar
vocês pra vivenciarem comigo
é uma situação e quem quiser quem sente
à vontade pode fechar os olhos
então eu queria que vocês se imaginassem
quando crianças quando criança
uma criança muito feliz uma criança que
tinha um vínculo muito forte com os pais
com a família a que vivia no interior de
minas que tinha uma infância de muita
liberdade uma liberdade tão grande que
aos 10 anos de idade você aprendeu a
dirigir seu pai permitiu isso
seu pai permitir que você tivesse
liberdade de fazer algumas escolhas que
hoje em dia representa um risco para
algumas crianças e essa criança tinha
muito amor tinha oportunidades de de
viver coisas como ir pescar com o pai
sair de barco pelo tabaco e só os 10
anos de idade vocês e uma história que
eu peço que quando vocês abrirem os
olhos
vocês imaginem na uti de um hospital e
não te preocupava tanto onde você estava
mas a única coisa que você pediu foi eu
quero uma escova de dentes e um copo com
água
e essa criança era eu
abrindo os olhos depois de alguns dias
eu não sei quantos dias
não me lembro direito e olha em volta e
ver algumas pessoas tristes poucas
pessoas não é porque não tem não pode
entrar
gente e já me vieram com uma notícia
você não pode beber água você está numa
uti
eu não entendia por que mas enfim e
dentro dessa uti eu fui questionando
algumas coisas né
cadê meu pai e minha mãe eu respondi eu
tô minha mãe tinha falecido num acidente
de carro que eu estava
minha irmã também faleceu e alguns dias
depois eu não sei quantos dias eu fui
pru quarto que era mais isolado mas não
era a uti e ir lá nesse quarto vieram
mais notícias de que meu pai que estava
em outra unidade de também muito isolada
tinha acabado de falecer aí eu me lembro
que foram 13 dias após o acidente
o acidente foi no feriado de 21 de abril
eo meu pai faleceu no dia 2 de junho dia
3 de maio um dia depois do aniversário
do meu irmão
por sorte eu fui muito amada e e teve
toda essa liberdade assim essa permissão
de ser uma criança livre o que me deu
muito conteúdo para que eu sobrevivência
tudo isso mas pior que perder meus pais
está na condição de cadeirante que eu
fui descobrir também com um dia depois
não é porque eu tentava me mexer na cama
e não conseguia me virar porque eu só
gostava de dormir de bruços e eu não
conseguia sair foram me contar que eu
não ia poder andar que eu ia precisar de
uma cadeira de rodas beleza e cada
notícia que vim assim escorrer uma
lágrima e tal aí eu lembrava que eu
gostava de mim hoje pedir a minha tia
para levar me hoje na janta pra mim
estava tudo certo eu não tava eu não
entendi a dimensão de tudo isso talvez
por ser uma criança e peça proteção
assim da inocência ainda não sabia o que
vinha é e aí as conseqüências desse
acidente foram maiores no sentido dada a
quebra da estrutura familiar
eu tinha mais dois irmãos que que não
estavam no acidente um de 17 e outro de
11 11 para 12 eu estava
10 para 11 anos de idade e perdi
totalmente a estrutura familiar
esse meu irmão mais velho se tomou
tornou extremamente agressivo eu acho
que porque foi sobrecarregado com tudo
que aconteceu eu acho que ele via minha
imagem de toda a desgraça que aconteceu
mas eu dentro de mim eu sabia que eu não
era merecedora daquela raiva dele aquela
agressividade dele eu sabia que eu
precisava e podia muito mais porque eu
já tinha eu tinha referência do que era
tem amor do que era ter família do que
era ter abrigo do que era ter
acolhimento nos meus pais
então dentro de mim e não permitia que
isso tomasse conta e eu desistisse de
tudo
foi com isso que eu tive oportunidade de
promover land a a partir do convite de
uma tia
conheci muitas pessoas bacanas
importantes que fazem parte da minha
vida até hoje pessoas que me
proporcionaram estudar que pagar uma
faculdade pra mim e eu me dei conta de
que a minha vida não estava sendo muito
legal eu ia eu ia seguindo assim eu ia
conquistando as coisas pessoas gostavam
de mim e proporcionavam coisas boas mas
eu não dava valor a mim porque eu estava
numa fase com zona não para 23 anos 24
já estava terminando a faculdade ea
minha rotina era sair beber e fumar como
a gente diz hoje seguir o baile é seguir
o baile as coisas vão acontecendo eu não
produzia nada absolutamente nada nem
para mim nem para os outros
eu só deixava coisa acontecer e aí eu
vou narrar 33 fatos a partir de a partir
disso que que me fizeram tomar atitudes
em mim e que consequentemente
transformaram também a vida de outras
pessoas nem que se espelharam em mim por
algum motivo
o primeiro fato foi eu queria colocar
isso aqui que é uma coisa muito bacana
que a maioria das pessoas pensa que
alguém que quis se tornou deficiente que
adquirir uma deficiência física por um
acidente uma coisa tão trágica pode
pensar que a pessoa não vai ser feliz
não vai conseguir ter alegria não vai
conseguir ter felicidade mas a
paraplegia
me colocou em situações que eu nunca
imaginaria viver
se eu fosse aquela menina com os pais
que o pai mimava porque eu era a caçula
que tinha tudo o que queria que
precisava até mais do que do que
precisava né
então assim eu sempre vejo esse lado
positivo da deficiência que me colocou
em contato com pessoas e com as
situações que eu nunca viveria se não
fosse isso e aquele fato ruim né que que
eu falei pra vocês que eu vou narrar que
é o primeiro que me colocou em contato
com o esporte
foi através da trombose
eu tive uma trombose em 2005 eu estava
terminando a faculdade é pelo uso de
anticoncepcional é e aí teve uma
trombose na perna esquerda e comecei a
questionar situações tipo quais o que me
levou a ter uma trombose o uso do
anticoncepcional cigarro bebida e na
atividade física não fazia exercício
nenhum era ver se há regras a disciplina
eu era muito assim solta e achava que as
coisas tinham que ser assim na minha
hora do jeito que eu queria se eu não
quisesse fazer nada de atividade física
não ia fazer nada e amy me fazer mudar
de revezamento
então a trombose me trouxe a
possibilidade de conhecer o esporte
paraolímpico é de me tornar campeão
mundial de viver coisas que eu não
poderia viver se não fosse um esporte
que eu acho que o esporte depois da
escola é é uma uma ferramenta de
transformação e de educação muito grande
porque eu pude me do mar um pouco
através do esporte dodoma essa
insatisfação acinte de ter que seguir
regras né
e eu fiz uma escolha assim eu não posso
me acomodar que nessa vida que eu tô e
muito menos lamentar porque eu contribuí
para isso né para trombose acontecendo
na minha vida eu podia ter evitado podia
ter pensado em ter uma vida mais
saudável
então resolvi ser atleta acolhi o que o
professor me falou que eu tinha um
potencial físico acreditei nisso
em menos de um ano foi convocada um ano
o treino foi convocada para a seleção
brasileira parte participei dos jogos
pan americanos do rio em 2009 eu fui
campeão mundial 2010 campeão mundial
2011 medalhista no para bandido méxico
duas medalhas de bronze onde não uma de
prata e uma de bronze e agora em 2015 é
duas medalhas de bronze em toronto no
canadá
eu mudei não só a minha vida todos
aqueles aquelas pessoas ali
são pessoas que são da minha equipe hoje
são atletas três técnicos e 12 atletas
pessoas que vieram de outros estados
menores de idade que saíram de casa com
15 anos porque acreditaram nos sonhos
que elas tinham de serem atletas e serem
campeãs e tem potencial para isso vivem
com salário do praia clube com o salário
que o governo paga de bolsa atleta então
sim a partir de mim da criação da equipe
para limpa no praia clube em 2010 após
maus resultados em 2009
ah eu sou responsável pela mudança assim
de certa forma indireta na vida dessas
pessoas eu me orgulho muito disso mas eu
acho que o maior ganho assim é é meu
sábio não sei o quanto eles valorizam
estar numa equipe que é a única equipe
do brasil que paga salário para seus
atletas
então isso pra mim é grandioso em 2009
ataque a foto do do lado mundial um
pouco antes de entrar numa prova é o
segundo fato que eu quero nadar pra
vocês que ninguém nesse mundial da
equipe técnica acreditava que eu seria
medalhista porque eles fizeram uma
reunião minutos ante um dia antes da
competição começar e fizeram uma infeliz
previsão de medalhas de chances de
medalhas de cada atleta poderia
conquistar ali naquele mundial
eu fiquei esperando até o final da
reunião e meu nome não apareceu ninguém
falou meu nome e ninguém lembrou que eu
estava ali
liguei pro meu técnico chorando falando
poxa será que não né será que é real
essa essa previsão deles mas a gente
batalhou tanto a gente treinou tanto a
gente
tem tanta certeza que a gente podia ter
resultados bons porque será nem que meu
nome não está ali e eu podia ter
acreditado na previsão deles mas graças
a deus eles estavam muito errado eu fui
ao pódio três vezes eu fui a primeira
mulher a el foi um campeonato de mundial
de piscina curta que é de 25 metros
eu fui a primeira mulher subir no pódio
a primeira mulher com o ouro neste
mundial
e não foi só um ouro foram dois ouros e
uma prata e assim a minha carreira deu
uma guinada depois disso porque eu não
era ninguém aí de repente num mundial
que foi feito no rio de janeiro ganhou
três medalhas né
e nessa época veio muita mídia
espontânea assim foi muito bacana pra
minha carreira pra mim também pra
afirmar mais uma vez que eu estava no
caminho certo e eu aí a partir daí
acreditei que acreditar em mim é o que
faria toda a diferença e não que os
outros não é isso aí é uma coisa que a
gente vive muito em função do que os
outros acham que a gente é capaz ou não
e eu acho que o negócio é acreditar na
gente e ponto final na e contar com quem
acredita também na gente que no caso meu
técnico foi muito importante também a
gente está junto desde 2007 e e cada um
ensinando todos os dias uma coisa para o
outro
depois de 11 anos gente na natação é a
terceira questão que eu quero contar pra
vocês
depois de 11 anos tendo resultados acho
que poderiam ser melhores sim ou sim
talvez eu tivesse me dedicado mais mas
isso já passou
é eu não consigo ter melhorar meus
resultados desde 2015 desde o parapan em
toronto
foram os meus últimos ótimos resultados
e como que um atleta vive sem resultado
eu eu sou movida também a vaidade eu
gosto de ganhar eu gosto de estar em
evidência e eu acho que para todo atleta
ganhar que seja desse mesmo né é muito
importante eu estou falando de ganhar
dos outros e sim de mim de melhorar meus
tempos de nadar melhor e de evoluir como
atleta é mas eu decidi
ao invés de desistir da natação desistir
do esporte cai
alguns ficam me zoando
porque eu sou mais velho tem 35 anos e
tem os de 1514 lá eles estão visando que
eu sou velho é por isso que eu não tenho
resultados
eu não me acomodei e eu resolvi mudar
mas mudar de esporte
então eu fui para são paulo algumas
semanas atrás para ser uma semana lá por
conta própria eu fui atrás de um novo
esporte experimentei a corrida em
cadeira de rodas
gostei muito mas nesse meio do caminho o
mesmo professor que me chamou atenção
pro meu corpo e para o potencial que eu
tinha físico me chamou e falou se que é
o quê
no atletismo eu quero resultados que eu
não estou tendo na natação por que tá
não está dependendo mais do meu esforço
e da minha mudança de hábitos de
resultado na natação
então eu queria um esporte no qual
pudesse usar um equipamento que me
deixasse num mais igual às outras que
todas estariam numa cadeira correndo
é uma cadeira diferenciada de corrida e
natação não não é assim depende do tom
das possibilidades do físico de cada um
nem alguns têm mais dentro da minha
categoria outros - e aí ele falou 'você
quer resultado então você vai para a
canoagem e eu vou te falar porque e aí
me colocou em contato com o chefe da
confederação brasileira de paranoá gem
explicou qual é o cenário atual do
brasil pouquíssimas mulheres que que
fazem a paracanoagem
eu fui então beleza eu vou lá e dentro
de uma semana eu já fechei já consegui
comprar o caiaque já conseguiu um
patrocinador para pagar metade desse
caiaque e tocou renda atrás do que eu
acredito que é o meu potencial e por
isso eu tenho que contar pra vocês uma
história ali lá em são paulo e e se
calhar que não é o de competição é um
caiaque assim mais estável que a gente
estava fazendo um teste eo técnico lá é
eu nunca me contentei com mais ou menos
eu nunca me contentei em com coisas
diferentes daquilo que eu acreditava que
eu podia ter que eu mereço ter e é por
isso que eu estou em busca de algo
diferente na minha vida e eu acho que
quem se as oportunidades vão aparecer a
gente tem que criar las né
e foi o que eu fiz em outras são paulo
eu atirei numa cor
acabei acertando em outra e eu tenho
certeza que eu vou ter bons resultados
na na paracanoagem
e eu queria dizer pra vocês uma coisa
que eu esqueci o nome dele o rapaz dos
óculos falou que estava tendo uma frase
que é a gente pode mudar e dá pra mudar
e podem começar hoje eu acho que a gente
não tem que esperar eu não tenho que
esperar mais um ano para ver se vou ter
resultado na natação eu não tenho que
esperar mais 11 anos
então assim vamos mudar a gente quer
mudar a gente pode começar hoje e essa
minha mensagem esse é meu está grande e
quem quiser me adicionar me seguir
conhecer um pouco mais da minha história
eu agradeço demais às outras histórias
que contribuíram muito também para a
minha vida e atenção de vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]